[Music]
and loosen up news submitted by JK is my
favorite it teacher was suspended after
the school found out she is also a pole
dancing instructor that's that semester
can I go to it now she's suspended well
for how long hold dancing is so
different now than what it was exercise
yeah so there's six plays in North
Carolina oh I get it
that's a part of the Bible Belt it just
clicked everyone I get it a lot of those
states in that area they're trying to
like get rid of evolution taught in
schools and they want to have like
seriously theory yeah I mean there's
like whole committees and [ __ ] like they
go into City Hall like trying to get
creationism taught as science that
bothers me why can't religion and
science coexist anyway so this teacher
her name is Candice Mason so she posted
a video on her private Facebook page of
her dancing like pole dancing cuz she's
also a pole dancing instructor on the
side that's dog uncle mother of two she
has a master's in psychology bachelor's
in English and a certificate in
phlebotomy if you guys were curious
about her background
what is phlebotomy like one day I got it
like a month no actually I don't
remember dammit if I did take the class
though and I was certified well I'm not
flip for a bottom Asst so I can't say
[ __ ] it wasn't much every week on the
part of this whole roster of stuff like
that is pretty funny it's kind of like
Spelling Bee champion Plus this Plus
that's pretty up there those bali-ba
champion
I can't say how that resumes pretty
stacked though she's really stuck like
she's well versed in different areas
yeah so I'm gonna show you guys a video
clip of her talking about this and she
got though dancing I'm not gonna watch
and alysha's okay like she's spinning
around and talking okay cool see that
you picked the right - she has a bunk
bed a bunk bed I think it's a mosquito
net type of thing Candice Mason works in
Hope County she posted a video of her
dancing on her private Facebook page the
district got a senator they set a policy
that says employees should be role
models even when they're not at work
I've worked so hard to try to make sure
I can provide for my daughters for
myself for our livelihood to have it
jeopardized just for doing something
that I'm passionate about
well I think for her just to I mean just
this you have opposite sides do you you
could pull this all you want but when
you put it out to a public space it
becomes a little bit of an issue right
so you could get party do whatever want
and that those are all perfectly fine
but you put it out on Facebook for
people that looks like that your page is
private that's still not cool with you
like it's still public but this is the
space that we live in you don't mean
you're pregnant anybody can find
anything yeah and you're putting up a
video right now or your ass is out and
you're spinning around and it makes the
parents feel uncomfortable as an
educator I don't see anything wrong with
it but not all parents play was she in a
thong
yeah she's butt naked is that why was it
like short so she wasn't but maybe I
think it was like good bikini bottom
probably but why do they blur it because
it was on the music's on the news public
though only now not to wear bikinis on
the knees she probably had risque Oh on
the TV do they blow out Michael Phelps
when he dives into the water
let's see Wow itõs our risk a booty he
does don't come out take it out you
don't see any like nuts eggs have you
seen the speedos are getting tighter and
tighter and more slim and walking oh
there's a double standard for guys and
girls are always husband I always see
it's big little honker before he's human
you should be allowed to knit but girls
like I don't want high medals she should
that's my thing
everyone should do whatever the ones I
wish like society was just accepting
like oh I'm like hey all girls have
turned down show their nipples smell
like all guys have to show their nipples
just I'm done the mentality in society
like I wish it was easy for me to just
do that you know you know what for the
longest time I I didn't understand like
why underwear was not okay but bikinis
are okay and then why is this not okay
but swimming is okay it's because this
represents seduction and the act of
sexual flirtation and things like that
swimming in a pool is in a bikini does
there's a good time and place for
everything well like if you walk around
and
what that represents is [ __ ] me what
depends where you're walking around in
underwear cuz you if you did like a
social experiment and you're in
underwear by a fool then it's alright
[ __ ] [ __ ] underwear though
because if you're like grandpa have you
seen the beat the bikinis now it's like
a Brazilian thing what's the diff on the
front - you look like way skinnier you
can see vagina lips hanging out 90
series catalogues begin saying like we
should do an experiment like that for
people that are like oh that's to set
foot looks like alright let's bring the
experiment has already been done
yeah because no matter how shitty a
volleyball team is the bleachers are
always packed for women's volleyball
because those booty shorts even though
it's athletic and a sports they wear
speedo if it's on the beach do not talk
about like the indoor ones okay so even
though it's there it's not sexual
intention a lot of people are getting
their jollies off look you know that's
true cuz the indoor volleyball they it
covers more skin but that ass looks way
better than beach volleyball yup when
there's less you know to talk about yeah
because you don't think it should be in
that setting so becomes a little hotter
I like the shorts better than the
cheerleaders they have bikini bottoms
you could do this yeah like it's like ah
depends on their outfit I do like the
volleyball shorts do they look better I
think when it is like when you hit it be
- you said earlier its context right so
it's like yeah bikinis are fine next to
a beach but you wouldn't wear that at a
church that's what it meant
come in please so for cheerleader so
this is a private Facebook I mean I
don't think there's anything wrong with
all that saying if you're passionate
about it I don't mind it at all because
I know the difference between pole
dancing in a strip club yeah I'll leave
it is anything wrong the shift Club I
agree I'm with you about to see I don't
see anything wrong with it either what
I'm saying is is that within the context
of her career and putting it into a
public forum probably wasn't the best
night but it was in public it is
Facebook even though his private is
still in a public forum like the kids
aren't looking at me people can see if
it's a private Facebook that only her
friends can see so whose house ting her
then they have it's private so we snitch
yeah I snitched for me I look at the
whole person how they balanced
themselves out so if they're just like a
regular teacher if they do something
more risky I'm gonna get mad at her but
she does pole dancing she has a master's
that to me a good teacher yes if she had
a PhD she could be a hooker and I'm cool
with it is this how much you balance it
out I think there's worse to have like
I've had so many shitty teachers yeah
and it's like I wish they'd dance rather
have a good teacher who which doesn't
reverse 11 I'm sure the shitty teacher I
would use this as an excuse to fire her
which might be the case is an amazing
teacher people always make excuses to
fire like teachers look for her though
she says she already got her classroom
they're about to start the school year
she was prepared well she'd even start
yet no that's just I mean discrimination
and they're probably gonna do their
research and background check on the
teacher and they found something out I
mean I get it like that there's probably
shits and a parent's that are just like
acceptable G Cara if your kid was a
teacher was a pole dancer stripper
hookers instructor I'm with him like if
she's a grade he she he or she cuz there
was a male strippers dude uh if he was a
great or she was a great teacher then
that's all I care about cuz my kids
happy and having a cool education me too
I feel like we're very open-minded
because lately yeah I went to a
Christian Senior High right and this is
how [ __ ] petty those parents are like
there were multiple complaints to the
principal because the parents didn't
like my hair yeah and then they pulled
dance on her I had [ __ ] bangs dude
like it was just a little bit that the
Asian being like the super ya had those
and then I I did a different like what
once to know what I mean like the point
is it's like it bothered them that one
of the other students unchristian like
and I'm like what the [ __ ] does a
Christian boy well you know it's like
what if it was a part of my culture and
they had no [ __ ] clue what that was
and they wanted to make a comment say he
should be like us well that's funny
because Jesus was like the biggest
hippie and like look what I'm saying but
that's how petty these parents can be so
if they're that petty they could see
this and think that she's the devil
so that I could really I could see how
that play out there also could be like a
tone of like because she's black because
she has dress like because I mean she
has like three braids sorry that's yeah
and it's like there's so many she's a
woman a black woman with I think the
biggest issue here is just sad that
she's an educator and has to have a
second job because she's not getting
paid enough like that's fungi that's
pretty sweet that's not her second job
she's a part-time dancing instructure
it's also passion to it it could be your
life she says it's her livelihood
oh just partner two kids it's in contact
like like in a lot of African culture
like or a Caribbean culture like
Caribana is okay there's kids that go to
care bed now they're all in bikinis are
we shaking at us and looks like it's
like a really big Caribbean festival
once a year they have a huge parade oh
and some on top listen [ __ ] and live
like they're very decorative colorful
yeah it's gorgeous and it's like a part
of their culture and kids see then it's
like it's totally fine it's like it's
not sexual but it's like even if it is
sexual is not like demonized yeah yeah
but see but to your point you're
actually supporting this argument then
because this context yeah I mean we're
talking about the Bible Belt North
Carolina so within their support what do
you guys think about naked dogs in my
dick tips you could really make an
argument about everything
naked dogs are human because I want to
know what you were picturing your head
that made you laugh a shaved dog yeah
picture like a golden retriever and who
got shaven oh it's so unchristian like
we gotta put some clothes laughing well
you know how they come up with those
chicken diapers oh yeah those are kind
of dog does what we talked about no for
coop so indoor chicken it could catch
your poop or whatever what do they start
doing that for dogs and it's like
mandatory cuz like you know how big is
your [ __ ] we used to make patches
where you just want to hide everything
from everybody and then kids become
adults in the dorm or anything and
everything Oh
we're reverting back like within South
Asian culture it's like the worst thing
you do is have sex it's like I didn't
learn anything about sex I didn't learn
anything about sex until I went to
school and they taught it and I was like
whoo that's all you have kids hey nobody
else knew like nobody told and I still
haven't talked about sex with my parents
and you expect kids to just figure [ __ ]
on their own it's like you don't want
that it is terrible oh you had that know
my mom's weird dude she's [ __ ] open
woman so she'll just be like yeah you
should just come up to me one day she'd
be like no but it was like violence is
so ugly and like Indian cinema and
Bollywood like he'll show the most go
getting next chopped off and that's a
and they take a girl four-year-old or
watching us in the theater but that
looks like you can't kiss in a Bollywood
movie you can't do that it's like but
you can show the moles these things
right and then they cut yeah and then
they cut that's love it's like you can't
show a form of love but you're like
really mutilating people somebody could
turn into a [ __ ] eagle fly away you
shoot the eagle down see isn't that
crazy
I got I got an Indian question for you
so I have to [ __ ] ask this [ __ ]
alright so Kama Sutra yeah is that a
small thing like like a small sect or is
that I could talk about this forever the
Kama Sutra so let me just quickly cadets
down Kama Sutra yeah as a part of like
sexuality in ancient Indian culture yeah
just like Asian cultures wall was very
heavily tired but it's spiritual
sexuality is still taboo it is habit not
because we got colonized so we got this
came in and they said have all religion
everything was was like there's rules
after the British came in everything he
became Christianized every religion in
India became Christianized even my
religion which is the most open free
thinking it's like Buddhism it's very
similar to Buddhism it's the most open
free thinking religion but there's so
many rules now there so you can't do
this you can't have sex before it but it
doesn't say anything so it landed with
Christianity so I think when the
colonizers came in they just literally
just [ __ ] everything up yeah almost
Sutra became a bad thing and sex became
bad that's like yeah
when sexuality was very open before we
get behind college before like even the
Mughals came in there was a time where
sexuality was one of the
open freeing you look at you go to an
ancient Indian temple and you see
everybody just having sex on the murals
and this is a place of worship
yeah and this is where kids go and it's
like it was very open it was very loved
yeah it was all about love means there's
nothing negative against it yeah yeah
yeah I think because a bridge came here
like you guys are all this savage and
this is not christ-like and then they
just they erase are a whole spiritual
aspirant be a rebirth of that kind of
stuff of people I'm reading about this
because I'm like I'm like whoa we have
to our whole history wipes so now I'm
like interested in being like what words
are ancient spiritual traditions like
because we were all
[Music]